al grito de libertad a nuestro alcalde
unos 2.000 habitantes de melitópol
salieron a pesar de la presencia de
tropas rusas para exigir la liberación
de su líder el viernes se difundió este
vídeo de cámara de seguridad no
verificado en la parte superior de la
pantalla se ve a un hombre que se cree
que es el alcalde iván fedorov
arrastrado por soldados rusos el
presidente ucraniano condenó el
secuestro y pidió ayuda a francia y
alemania- para presionar a rusia en la
liberación de fedor el alcalde de kiev
también condenó al secuestro
los ocupantes dejaron la ciudad sin su
líder elegido para paralizar melitópol y
desmoralizar y conquistar a sus
habitantes es un acto de terror y de
la televisión local anunció que gali
nada en misión co antigua concejal fue
nombrada nueva alcaldesa sin haber sido
elegida y pensando que es leal a moscú
se comprometió a devolver melitópol a la
normalidad a usar y sustituir a los
funcionarios locales es sólo una de las
tácticas de rusia según el presidente es
de lenski también estaría en su lista a
los as la semana pasada el alcalde de
tomé el falleció tras recibir disparos
mientras distribuía pan y también según
selenski hay planes para convocar
referendos en zonas tomadas por rusia
como gerson situada en el mar negro es
un puerto estratégico y fue una de las
primeras ciudades en caer en manos de
las fuerzas rusas incluso en medio de
una protesta generalizada el sábado el
presidente selenski acusó a moscú de
planear una votación falsas y ocupante
en un territorio los invasores de la
región de gerzón intentan repetir la
triste experiencia de formar pseudo
repúblicas
en las redes sociales el jefe adjunto
del consejo local denunció el intento de
convertir jedson en una república
independiente escribió que esto
convertiría a la región en un agujero
sin esperanza sin vida ni futuro